uh my name is wenar guruswami I'm a
senior scientist uh here at the Science
Institute and also serving as uh its
interim acting director this semester
and uh it gives me great pleasure to
welcome you all uh to the Simons
Institute and this week's uh Workshop as
you know the Simons Institute is the
leading uh International venue for
collaborative research in theory of
computing and uh related fields it was
established in 2012 uh with a very
generous Grant from the Simons
Foundation which continues to support us
um very generously The Institute brings
together uh the world's leading
researchers in theory of computing as
well as connected Fields And as well as
the next generation of outstanding young
scholars and for focused collaborative
uh research on thematic programs so we
are now in the 10th year uh in the
second decade of programming and each
semester we have two programs that
attract several long-term visitors
Junior and senior to Berkeley and which
also include multiple workshops that
convene more short-term visitors and
today I would like to welcome you to the
third Workshop um on optimization and
algorithm design as part of the program
on data structures and optimization for
fast algorithms uh first I would like to
thank the organizers of this workshop
for their work in putting together a
great program so they are
Alina Rasmus King and uh Yuri
nrov um subit SRA and Rachel Ward so
let's give a round of applause to all of
them and uh just a few logistics for the
coming week before I hand it over to
Rasmus for introducing the workshop so
we have food before the first talk and
during the breaks just outside where you
were before for lunch you're on your own
but there are many excellent options uh
close by and we ask that you please uh
leave uh any food and drinks uh outside
the auditorium it really helps us keep
the auditorium clean as you see and if
you need to store your things during
lunch or other times there are lockers
in the other side of the building you
can use those and we have our
videographer omat far who will be around
through out to help with any um AV and
other issues and uh one thing is that if
any of you are active on um social media
like X or Twitter um and you know if
you're live tweeting from the workshop
if you do that please tag us at at
Simons Institute and we'll be sure to
retweet your post it kind of increases
the publicity of your Workshop if you're
doing that and finally I would like to
give a special uh thanks to our event
staff uh Ashley Freda and L for managing
all the logistics uh for this week's
event takes a lot of effort to put
together uh an intense Workshop like
this and uh you know thank and they will
also be on hand all week to answer any
logistical questions so with that I'll
hand it over uh to Rasmus to introduce
the workshop thanks and welcome and have
a
[Applause]
great thank you everyone uh first let's
start by giving an extra hint of
Applause to Elina because she's really
The Mastermind behind this
[Music]
Workshop ER and then uh so like I'll
only say two words about what we were
trying to do but I think we were trying
to think about the ways that
optimization comes about both as
continuous and combinatorial stuff in
some different fields people have very
different perspectives coming in this
Workshop I think and we're hoping that
it would be productive to bring you all
together also I Elena told me that we
have set a new record for registration
so people are excited to hear your talks
for those of you who who are speaking so
that's nice um during the talks we'll
try to get microphones out to people
that are asking questions so that they
can be heard by people who are listening
online but on top of that uh if you're a
speaker try to if you hear a question
maybe repeat the question for people
listening
online
um on top of that so uh today at 3:30 we
have a a lightning talk session where a
few people will give sort of five minute
talks uh just to get you you a chance to
meet some of the attendees that are not
giving a longer talk we still have one
slot left if anybody wants to give a
five minute talk uh spontaneously uh
between 3:30 and 4 you can tell me those
of you who already signed up uh I'll
send you an email but it would be good
if you have slides if you can send them
to me then I'll try to collect them all
on my laptop so we don't spend time
switching uh there's another important
Point uh which is that Tuesday Wednesday
and Thursday
we have this slightly mysterious time
slot called open discussions or or
something like that from 4:15 to five
and uh for these we've asked some of the
more senior attendees to uh so a five 45
minute slot each day we have or most
days two attendees speaking for
something like 20 minutes on what they
think of as promising directions in this
field so I'm hoping that for junior
people this could be a good way to think
about where should your research be
headed in the next few years get some
inspiration and we also should have
plenty of time to to talk about things
in these sessions however tomorrow uh so
Okay so Thursday we're going to hear
from omry Weinstein and David Wu
Wednesday we're going to hear from
suit and Yin
yui uh and tomorrow we're going to hear
from Rachel Ward but we could still use
more input tomorrow so if you want to do
a shorter uh spontaneously little talk
about what you think as of as exciting
open
directions uh tell me and we'll try to
squeeze you in as well tomorrow between
4:15 and 5 and importantly I should say
we tried to frame this a little bit
differently than the usual open problem
sessions in theoretical computer science
we were looking for people to say
something a bit broader than here's a
particular technical point that I've
been working on okay so I'm hoping these
sessions will will take like a more
broad perspective and and be exciting
for for all of us so again tomorrow we
still have a little bit more room for
people to show up and and talk there so
tell me if you're
interested okay I think that's uh all
the all the stuff I had to say so let's
uh B Welcome to our first Speaker
Melanie weba from Harvard
[Applause]
[Music]
so many things to the organizers for the
opportunity to speak um and my talk
today will be on exploiting geometric
structure in metric Valu
optimization um and that is in the
context of remanion optimization or
optimization on manifolds oh and I
should say important this is all joint
work with SRA
one yeah so this talk is in the context
of remion optimization optimization on
manifolds uh so I want to start with
just one slide of introduction um about
this class of problems and where we
might encounter them in the machine
learning or data science
context so in rem and optimization we
are trying to solve problems of the form
as written here on the slides so we have
a function that's defined on every manum
manifold and we want to find uh it its
minimum usually make some assumptions on
the underlying manifold that it's smooth
and connected but other than that it can
have any um geometric structure um and
problems of that form um we encounter
frequently in machine learning and data
science through three um examples are
shown here on the slide so one is
sampling and there's recently been a lot
of interest in um analyzing sampling
problems as optimization in the space of
measures so waserstein space which has a
geometric structure that's similar to a
manifold um and then um tools from uh
convergence analysis in optimization can
be used to understand uh or derive
theoretical guarantees for sampling
algorithms you might also sometimes want
to train machine learning models on
geometric domains um so on data that has
a geometric structure that field is
called geometric machine learning and
the the TR the optimization of the
training loss um could be viewed as as a
remion optimization problem and then um
a third class of such problems and that
is the examples that we will see in this
talk um are problems that involve metric
valed functions um and where those
metrices have a geometric structure that
we can parameterize as a manifold and
there are many classical algorithms or
subroutines and classical algorithms
that we can view as such optimization
problems and due to this like quite
broad um set of application of such
problems there's been a lot of interest
in developing algorithms um for these
problems um many of those arise from
generalizations of classical algorithms
to the reman setting so classical
algorithms like gradient descent Frank
Wolf um also second order optimization
methods and and many other classes um
have by now been extended to the reman
setting so to give some more examples on
this uh third class of problems that I
mentioned so where um we have metrics
valued uh optimization routines or sub
routines um that occure in uh machine
learning here on the slide are um few
such examples many of which I'm sure
you've encountered uh in your work
before all of those can be written as
optimization problems on metrices and
specifically on Metric manifolds um I've
written here those um underlying
manifolds you see a lot here PD that's
the manifold of positive de metries and
many any of the examples that we will
see in the talk um will be of that
form so if we if we take a step back and
think about how we might um solve such
optimization problems there is always
the option to use uh ukian methods right
we could use classical tools from ukian
optimization metrices or vector spaces
so it could use ukian optimization
methods um and then the specific
structure of the uh metrices that we're
working with would enter as a constraint
so if we optimizing our positive
definite metrices we would put a
positive definiteness constraint if we
are let's say in the example here of
kin's clustering um we have an
orthogonality we we are working with
orthogonal metrices then we would put an
orthogonality constraint um and and so
forth and now the idea with reman
optimization is to uh take the
perspective that these classes of
metrices correspond to a reman manifold
so in the case of positive definite
metrices that's the manifold of positive
definite metrices in the case of the
orthogonal orthogonality constraint
that's for instance the manifold and
then this parameterization already
implicitly encodes the geometric
structure of that class of metrices and
we don't have to impose that as an
additional constraint right so in in
that case in the remanion setting we can
solve these problems as an unconstrained
optimization problem and that's
oftentimes easier to do than a con and
that's one of the key motivations um for
why people have originally started to
look into uh remion
optimization a second point and that's
one that we will exploit um throughout
this talk is geodesic convexity um it
turns out that um there are functions
that are through the ukian lens
non-convex and therefore um challenging
in an optimization context but that
fulfill a notion of geodesic convexity
with respect to a reman metric so
basically if we parameterize such
problems in the reman setting then we
can solve solve um a convex problem and
and obviously that's that's highly
beneficial in the optim in the
optimization setting in this talk
specifically we will assume uh that the
problems have an additional structure uh
namely that they can be written as a
difference of convex functions and we
will properly introduce that class of
problems shortly um and see what what
that means but several of the example
problems here on the slide do fall into
that
category before we move to that let just
Define this notion of geodic convexity
that we already mentioned so this is
basically just the generalization of the
usual concept of convexity to the
remanion setting so this condition that
you see here on the slide should look
very familiar right that's the usual
convexity condition just now evaluated
along a geodesic gamma so we call that
geodesic is the shortest path between
two points on manifold and the specific
shape of that geodesic depends on the
geometry of the of the manifold the case
of positive definite metrices for
instance the example that we will see in
the talk that has a specific form that
we know and that we can um directly
Implement in practice this generalized
notion of convexity has in the
optimization context the same nice
properties that that we we usually have
with convexity so it guarantees that
there's a unique uh Global Optimum
meaning that if our algorithm finds a
local Optimum we can be sure that that
is the global Optimum and that's of
course highly desirable because that
means that we can derive Global
conversiones for
our okay so the class of problems that
we are interested in is as follows so
again our objective function is defined
on remion manifold but now We
additionally assume that it can be
written as a difference of two ukian
convex
functions and now the difference of two
convex functions is of course in general
non-convex and that makes the problem
challenging
to
solve in this talk we will look at a
subass of those problems where the
overall objective is in addition
geodesically convex so it might be ukan
nonconvex but it is geodesically convex
and in fact some of our sample problems
that we saw earlier and that are listed
again here on the slide fall exactly um
into that subass of problems and you
will see other examples uh later on at
the
top difference of convex optimization is
not a new topic there's been a lot of
work um on solving problems of that form
either with ukian or reman methods um in
in the ukan setting of course that's a
non-convex optimization setting so quite
challenging to do but nevertheless
they're good algorithmic approaches for
solving such problems um there's also
some work on um of course solving
geodesically convex um optimization um
and also difference of convex
optimization in the pr setting but what
has not done before is to kind of merge
the two apprach bres so to look at ukian
algorithms but to see whether that
additional structure that geodesic
convexity can be used to understand the
convergence properties of the algorithm
better and that's exactly the
perspective that we want to take
here so the the algorithms that we're um
analyzing in this talk are um cccp
algorithms that stands for convex
concave procedure and it's a very simple
ukian algorithm that I can um for you in
in one slide so so I will do that um so
we know that our objective function can
be written as a difference of two ukian
convex functions so in particular due to
the ukian convexity of H we have this
inequality that's written here in point
one that's just the usual convexity with
the terms we arranged and then we can
take that inequality and insert it into
the objective function and that gives us
a convex upper bound of the objective
function that we see here um in in 2 and
we denote as q and then the idea of the
cccp algorithm is to instead of directly
minimizing the objective function that
we successively minimized that upper
bound okay so that's really here in
point three and in order to do this we
have to solve um this sub problem on the
right hand side the so-called cccp orle
so basically we're minimizing this um
upper bound this C get
Q and then successively minimizing and
solving that sa problem um will give us
a monotonically decreasing sequence that
uh convert US to the uh the optimal
value of the original underlying
problem so at no point in this algorithm
have we used remanion tools right that's
a purely ukian algorithm we don't have
to compute remanion gradients we don't
have to compute uh exponential Maps or
parallel transport operators so all the
um comput of sometimes computationally
expensive tools that we have to compute
um in remanion optimization we avoid
Computing here it's a purely ukian
algorithm so there's no additional
overhead
from you're still minimizing this uh
upper
bound yes so but
[Music]
you're but you're you're still computing
xk+ one by minimizing over the manifold
right so that may involve optimization
how to solve that that's s problem we'll
get to that okay we'll get to that yeah
yeah so yeah that's a a good point so of
course in order to efficiently Implement
that we need to find a good way of
solving the CCP Oracle right and and we
we will get to that but so so for now
this is a a ukian
algorithm right we we might have to
think about how to solve the cccp
procedure but up until here we haven't
computed Anyan TOS it's a it's a ukian
algorithm and we also and that's been
known before so as I said those
algorithms have been um considered in
the in the previous literature and it's
known um that they do converge to a
local Optimum of the um of the
underlying original objective um this is
only to to a local Optimum right due to
non-convexity um and those results tend
to be um asmic convergence
guarantees so now
um in the in the analysis that we are
proposing here so this is for the for
the general class of problems that are
not necessarily geodesically convex but
if we're working if we're looking at the
subass of problems that is geodesically
convex um then we can give um a sharper
convergence analysis um in particular
under some mild regularity assumptions
we can show
that um in the geodesically convex
setting this algorithm converges to the
the clob optimum right we we now have a
a unique Global Optimum because we we
are in the geodesically convex setting
and in fact we can also use um the
geodesic convexity in the analysis to
derive sublinear convergence guarantees
um in particular we get um sublinear
rates so on the order of one overk where
the constants depend on the the geometry
of the man not going to go through the
proof here but it's similar to um that
of the the Miso algorithm um if you're
familiar with that
algorithm so now the The crucial part is
um so aside from that that is just an
iteration complexity right it doesn't
say anything about the complexity of
computing one of those iterations and it
assumes that we have found um a good
solution to um the cccp Oracle in each
um iteration now let's look at what is
actually involved with um solving that c
and it turns out that actually for many
problems in this um metric uh
optimization setting we can solve that
cccp Oracle in closed form so there's no
actual optimization protein involved in
solving the sub problem we have an
analytic solution um to the cccp Oracle
and that renders the overall algorithm
into a simple fixo iteration and here
are some examples um where that is the
case um many of those were known um
beforehand but with the previous
convergence analysis we could only get
asmic convergence guarantees right but
with the now um using the fact that
those objective functions are
geodesically convex we can get a global
non- asmic convergence in
our I'm wonder if you could give some
intuition for um at least one could you
give some intuition for at least one
example that why it can be a difference
of convex functions in ukian space but
geodesically convex so we will see some
some concrete examples and also how to
fix point iterations if that doesn't
answer your question we can go go back
to it um just just one more note before
we we get to actual examples um so of
course there might be settings where we
cannot solve the cccp Oracle in closed
form right and then um solving the sub
problem the only thing we can do is to
call a numerical solver and um solve the
sub problem approximately so we won't
have an exact solution and that will
introduce an approximation error um in
that setting we we can show that we can
still um get um sublinear um rates as
long as we get a sufficiently good um uh
approximate solution to the sub problem
and then that only um that makes our
constants slightly slightly worth our
convergence rates um but we can still uh
show um a sub new rate um but the
interesting cases are really the
settings where we have a close from
solution and um where the cccp algorithm
uh becomes a simple fix Point iteration
so now let me show you some examples of
this um the first one is um the problem
of computing square roots of positive
definite metrices and that can be
written as a problem on the manifold of
positive definite metrices as follows
this is here written with respect to the
S Divergence uh so this is a setting
where the cccp orle can be solved in
closed form and this uh using that
closed form gives this simple fix Point
iteration so that would be um one
example and the objective here has a
difference of convex um structure for
that um fix Point iteration that was
known before it's actually derived by S
TR in in a paper um and in that paper
there were only ASM totic convergence
guarantees given but now with our
framework we can actually show that it
has a sub automation complexity and that
is also corroborated or we see this also
Illustrated in the numerical examples
the CC CP approach here is shown um in
the red curve and then the other curves
uh in the plot are first order V man
optimization methods we see here that
the cccp method um outperforms them for
all um the sample inputs here um but
overall it's like um they they clearly
all lie in the same like complexity
class um and and first order methods
have a sublinear uation complexity so
this aligns with with what we see um in
in our
Theory
um this the second example that I I want
to mention and focus on for the rest of
the talk is the computation of PR
complete constants that's a problem that
arises in the con in the context of PR
complete inequalities that's a class of
inequalities um in functional analysis
that has U many applications and
Connections in various areas of
mathematics computer science and
statistics um many of you probably have
encountered before examples of complete
inequalities such as fers in quality for
instance um of theoretical um this this
problem is also of theoretical
importance due to connections to the
operator scaling problem which is a very
um important uh problem in theoretical
computer science and has many
connections to other important problems
such as maximum likelihood estimation
for instance or metric scaling um all of
those are special instances of the
operator scaling problems problem and
and so is the the computation of press
complete
so on the slide here written is the the
general form of the press complete
inequality um that's determined by a set
of linear Transformations script A and
uh exponents
W and then um so those two the linear
Transformations and exponents are known
as The Press complete datum that
determines the particular complete
inequality and then we want to decide
whether there exists a finite constant
such that that inequality is true so
basically if there's a if this is a
non-trivial
inequality um and if so then we call the
Press complete datum feasible and in
that case we want to know what the exact
value of that constant C is which
characterizes um the overall
inequality and and F are we valued non-
negative functions so this this problem
of understanding whether the Press
complete datum is uh feasible
and what the the constant might be can
be written as an optimization task on
the manifold of positive definite
metrices that's written out here so
basically we want to compute an absolute
approximate solution to that uh
constant that problem um has received a
lot of interest over the years so
originally it was proposed in the in the
mid 70s in um several papers by Pras
comp and leap um so they defined this
problem class and also already showed
that if we view this as an optimization
problem the optimizer is attained over
positive metries so we can phrase it as
a problem um over the positive definite
metrices and then about 20 years later
um an algorithm for this problem was
given by gitz or for the more General
operator scaling problem but then also
giving a solution to um the the problem
of computing press complete constants
that's a purely ukian algorithm and in
his original paper he gives uh asmic
convergence guarantee so he shows that
the algorithm converges but not how how
fast so no non asmic convergence
analysis that was then given in a series
of paper papers by uh many of the main
authors of those papers are victorson
Olivier gar and alen Sue um and they
actually applied a reman perspective to
this problem so they noticed that this
objective this underlying objective
function of computing PR complete
constants is geodesically convex
and use tools from remanion optimization
to derive to to give a non asmic
convergence analysis um of grit's
algorithm um the results that you get
from that analysis and then from some
improved analysis that came out more
recently um is that the iteration
complexity is linear so log on the order
of log one over Epsilon um it's
conjectured that it's overall a linear
convergence so that um and sorry overall
um an efficient algorithm um the current
best um results still have an
exponential dependency on the Press
complete dat on the the the bit
complexity the size of the press
complete datum so this is not um this is
still an an open problem linear
convergence with polom bit length is
still um open in the general case we're
also not solving that here but what we
want to do is uh to give a new geometric
perspective on this problem um using
some of the tools um and the CCP
analysis that we that we talked about
earlier in the
talk um in order to do this um we
analyze a slightly different formulation
of the problem than um what was used to
derive git's algorithm but one that
nevertheless goes goes right back to the
original work by Pras Le namely we um
look at this optimization problem um
again defined on the manifold of
positive def metries um that has a
difference of convex structure and it is
geodesically convex so basically it fits
into our um uh subass of of problems uh
for our cccp
framework and importantly the cccp
Oracle in that case can be solved in
closed form and that gives the simple um
iterative map that you see here um on
the
slide um if we um implement this this
method and try it out on some sample
inputs we we get the following results
so the colors are as4 in red we see the
cccp algorithm and then the other um
Curves in the the plot are reman first
order method so variance of reman
gradient descent and we see here again
cccp beats the remanion methods but this
time actually quite substantially right
in particular as the size of the input
increases so as we look at the the plots
on the right hand side we see that it
very substantially um improves over the
first order
methods and based on that that kind of
gives us a hint that the sublinear
convergence rate that we get from the
previous cccp analysis um is actually
conservative right so that just gives us
an upper bound and looking at these
plots um it looks like that that might
be uh too conservative and the
convergence of that fixed Point
iteration is actually much faster than
something in order to um analyze that um
with uh some some more detail um we put
a different geometric lens on the
problem so in the previous discussion um
we have said that positive definite
metrices could be feed as a ukan space
could be feed as a reman space with the
the usual um remanion metric that we put
on positive definite metrices that
arises from the fenus product but we can
also for instance put um a different
metric um like this one the Thomson part
metric on the positive definite metrices
uh that gives us a non-re geometry a
finate geometry on the positive definite
metrices and that turns out to be a
critical um ingredient in in our
analysis um a second key ingredient is
regularization so we're not solving um
directly the objective function that you
saw earlier but we put a regularizer to
that and then rederive the fix Point
iteration and this is the map um that we
get and those two ingredients are are
crucial to um give uh linear convergence
analysis um namely we can show that this
regularized iterative map contracts
strictly under the Thompson
metric this is something that we could
not show with the the previous method
that was not regularized and we were
also not able to show this in the
remanion setting but with the
regularized map and the uh finsler
geometry the the the setting that um and
th the positive definite metrices with
the Thomson metric we were able to show
a strict uh
contraction and then um we can analyze
the the rate of the
contraction um and we can in fact show
that the regularized map um converges um
or gives an Epsilon approximation to the
Press complete constant with an
iteration complexity that is linear so
on the order of log 1/ Epsilon and the
the in this this formulation there's a
polinomial dependence on the um uh press
complete datum on the on the complexity
of the press
complete but unfortunately there's one
caveat so this does not solve the
general conjecture because this is only
subject to suitable
initialization um so we we know from um
a paper by Bennett carber Chris Christ
and Tow that um the Press complete
constant um
that there's an an an upper and lower
Bound for um the optimum at which the
the Press complete constant is attained
um and uh those upper and lower bounds
depend on two constants little data and
capital data and while we know that
those constants exist um we currently
don't know how to efficiently compute
those constants so this is not construct
not a constructive proof um and we also
don't know if it can be done efficiently
so that is the the open um uh the the
open problem in the setting we have um a
regularized map that at least um
empirically um does seem to converge at
a linear rate and it has a polinomial um
complexity in the Press compete um in
the the size of the press complete datum
um but it is only subject to a good
initialization and in order to um
completely solve the problem we would
need to be able to efficiently compute
isable initialization which is currently
open and that brings me to the end of my
talk so there are two um works that that
I I talked about in this talk the first
one um was a a framework for cccp
algorithms for difference of convex um
optimization where the objective
function is geodesically conx um in this
setting we provide uh Global non- ASM
totic conversion guarantees for some
instances of that problem class um the
the first uh Global non asmic converence
guarantees um in particular in settings
where this this crucial subar and the
CCP Oracle can be solved um efficiently
this gives a very practical algorithm um
as you've briefly seen in the uh in the
numerical experiments and then in the
second part of the talk we um looked had
a closer look at one specific instance
of that problem class namely the problem
of computing press complete constants um
this is one of the instances where in
fact um we have a close term solution to
um the cccp orle so very um efficient
fix Point iteration and then for that
too we can um establish fast non asmic
convergence guarantees subject to a good
initialization which is the the key open
problem here and then in the future of
course um it would be great to to solve
this this problem and um find an
efficient way to um compute an efficient
initialization for this um ior and for
complete constants but more generally I
think um this this structure um this
this problem class that that we are um
considering here for the cccp framework
um is can be found in many um machine
learning applications and I think
there's lots of um potential for
applying such uh such remion tools um to
um various problems in machine learning
that involve metri
optimization
[Applause]
any further
questions very simple question I imagine
um you assume that the function is uh
jally convex the the big one yes but
then in your sub problem you're solving
uh your sub problem as the concave part
of the objective that is linearized is
that is that a problem or like given
that the original function is you know C
can that be a problem ever the fact that
you're assuming that original function
is is coming the geometry and then
you're not actually minimizing that
functioning the problem so
the not not sure I completely understand
so the solving the the sub problem
itself depending on what specific
problem we're looking at that is that is
certainly a key step that has to be
worked out right we aring here there are
a lot of instances of this problem where
we can solve that in closed form so
there's actually no optimization routine
needed for the sub
problem but you're saying that in
general if like from the geodesic
convexity if we get any special
structure for the sub problem is that
the
question yeah or maybe simpler the fact
that you linearize in the ukan space
does that make the function potentially
n in
the
space so the the the constru struction
the construction of the CCP or doesn't
doesn't use any geometric structure
right well like not in the general not
in the channel setting so you can view
this as a sort of the right hand side as
a as a blackbox let's say and then there
are instances where this has a Clos from
solution so we don't have to worry about
an optimization routine and then there
are other settings where we can solve it
in closed form and then we have to for
specific problems look at how can we
efficiently solve this right and
depending on the specific structure of
the problem maybe there's some geometric
structure that can help us solve the sub
problem but that will be depending on
the specific instance of the problem
yeah so the fact that the overall
objective is geodesically convex does
not immediately give sort of a general
insight into that sub problem it's more
the the analyzing the iteration
complexity of the algorithm that is
influenced by the gity and that's that's
where we're using it right to to get
this this result how many iterations do
we need to get an Epsilon approximate
solution assuming we can solve the sub
problem in some way yeah makes
sense when you say asymptotic
convergence you meant convergence of the
function values right do we have any
like results on the asymptotic
convergence to the eates like because
you have xstar right it can be different
X Stars right do have any results on on
convergence to the solution which is not
the function
values like here like can you show the
conversion
rates so so when I say asmic so just to
clarify so asmic convergence that means
the algorithm will converge but I I
can't quantify how fast that will happen
yeah yeah whereas in a setting like this
right I can say after K iterations I'm
on the order of one over K close or like
the the optim the optimality Gap is on
the order of one over K yeah and the
question is like uh what exactly conver
does iterates XK converge to X star or
the values of f of XK convers to f of x
star so so I get this this
inequality I'm sorry I might be I I I
can talk with you in like okay after Le
sorry any other questions
for is an
accelerated sorry is an accelerated this
um not that I'm aware for cccp in
general um yeah not that not that I'm
aware all right so let's thank Melanie
again
[Music]